mais hors murs du ballet le sénat comme
vous ne l'avez jamais entendue lundi 7
février 1853 lundi 20 janvier 1919
65 ans et 348 jours séparent ces deux
lundi le premier a le parfum de fête des
soirs de balle n'ayez pas peur avance et
tournoyer frayez vous un chemin parmi
les robes en taffetas et les costumes en
soie et surtout admirer la splendeur de
celle qu'on appelle alors la salle du
trône ce soir on line augure où que se
pose le regard tout brille tout rispondi
dorures en eau dorures en badaud ruraux
murat goût de l'or quand tu nous tiens
d'ailleurs retenez votre souffle il
arrive le fautif celui qui prône le
décorum et la splendeur napoléon iii en
personne ici c'est sa salle son trône
l'empereur a demandé alphonse de gisors
de réaliser une galerie du trône pour le
sénat impérial
là où se trouvait l'ancienne salle des
séances de la chambre des pairs et de
salon attenant et puis il vient tout
juste d'épouser eugénie de mon tir haut
lui qui a le goût des balles le prétexte
est tout trouvé celui de ce soir sera
grandiose ou ne sera pas 6000 carton
d'invitation sont envoyés
que dira la soirée fut mémorable le
lendemain on eu mal au pied et peut-être
aussi un peu la tête côté potins raymond
trop plomb sénateurs bien trop président
du sénat aurait dansé avec l'impératrice
tandis que son épouse vlc au bras de
l'empereur
lundi 20 janvier 1919 c'est une toute
autre sorte de fête qui se tient dit si
le réveil après l'immense est atroce
cauchemar la grande guerre est
officiellement terminée depuis plus de
deux mois mais la paix at elle vraiment
commencé
250 des plus hautes personnalités de
france d'europe et des états unis y
travaillent
élaborant à coups de négociations et
tractations le futur traité de
versailles
la conférence de paris a débuté il y a
deux jours et le sénat a invité les
participants le temps d'un déjeuner au
premier rang du banquet qui portera
bientôt son nom l'invité d'honneur
thomas woodrow wilson président des
états unis d'amérique
autour de lui georges clemenceau
président du conseil français lloyd
george premier ministre du royaume uni
et orlando président du conseil italien
antonin dubost président du sénat c'est
vrai ça wilson en ces termes la tâche
est gigantesque mais elle est digne de
votre pays habitué aux grandes
entreprises d'une autre vieil ouvrier de
la civilisation occidentale et de vous
monsieur le président de votre grand
coeur et de votre haute intelligence et
que nous saluons d'un joyeux espoir et
d'une ardente acclamations
des lendemains n'apportèrent qu une paix
provisoire mais l'espace que vous
traversez avait trouvé son nom la salle
des conférences
avant de quitter les lieux une dernière
question que mange-t-on quand on tient
le sort du monde entre ses mains bar à
la vénitienne en hors-d'oeuvre celle de
pauillac moissonneuses dindonneau à la
broche il fond d'artichaut au velouté
pour le plat de résistance
gravé médoc en carafe en guise
d'accompagnement
[Musique]